qu'est ce que vous voyez qu'est ce que
vous voyez
l'essentiel est sous nos yeux et
sommes-nous en capacité de le voir pour
éclairer cette question je vais vous
partager une expérience en 1999 j'étais
avec un collègue de travail partie
trieste re pour un colloque sur
l'interculturalité et pour y parvenir on
mangeait la mer et au loin ce que j'ai
vu c'était un porte avions puis on va
continuer notre chemin on est arrivé à
destination le colloque était basé au
bord du port et on avait un bateau de
guerre américains amarré en bas et
pendant trois jours en fait de quoi on a
parlé on a parlé de dialogue de capacité
à se comprendre à se parler
gérer des conflits ingéré la diversité
agir et des cultures différentes et ce
dont je me souviens c'est que on était
surtout gênés par le bruit des soldats
américains dans les restaurants voilà
les trois jours se sont écoulés et puis
on est reparti on a pris le même chemin
et là on en mange est aussi la mère
et je vois le même porte avions qui
étaient à l'horizon sauf que là j'ai vu
qu'il y avait des avions sur le
porte-avions et là j'ai compris compris
dans le sens où j'ai vu et compris ce
que ça voulait dire que des avions sur
un porte-avion sa signifier qu'on était
au début de la deuxième guerre du kosovo
que la gamme était imminente
les bateaux de guerre étaient présents
et on a été incapable pendant trois
jours de traiter le sujet entre nous on
n'a pas saisi cette opportunité de se
dire mais nous sommes là pour travailler
sur les différences culturelles qui
peuvent aller jusqu'à des conflits voire
même jusqu'à une guerre elle était à nos
pieds et on n'a pas su en parler ça a
été un véritable électrochoc je me suis
dit mais si nous sommes des personnes
qui sommes en chemin qui sommes un petit
peu consciente puisque on s'intéresse à
ces premiers matic qu'on n'a pas été en
capacité de voir ça
mais alors qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
pour des personnes qui sont pas avec
cette vigilance avec cette curiosité
qu'est ce qui va bien pouvoir se passer
ça a été tellement fort pour moi de me
dire que c'était sous vos yeux et que
moi je n'avais rien vu que nous il faut
faire quelque chose donc en rentrant
j'ai eu envie d'écrire un ouvrage pour
témoigner de cette de ce moment là après
j'en ai écrit d'autres sur le sujet et
cet électrochoc n'a pas fait que me
réveiller il a aussi déterminé la suite
de ma vie il a vraiment donné une
impulsion forte et puis
les jours ont passé et puis je suis
revenu dans mon quotidien et ça n'est
que rétrospectivement que je me rends
compte que 1999 a été en fait un
changement radical dans ma vie après 7
cette année là je suis parti vivre et
travailler à paris j'étais salarié donc
là j'étais vraiment installée dans une
vie normale et je pense qu'il ya eu un
petit peu d'endormissement de cette
prise de conscience que j'avais eue et
très rapidement en fait la vie m'a
rattrapé il y avait eu dans un premier
temps le départ dans des conditions tout
à fait déplaisant du dirigeant kim avait
recruté qui a été viré par un autre
dirigeant donc en deux jours j'ai trouvé
que c'était très brutal compte tenu du
fait que nous étions censés apporter un
conseil aux entreprises ont souhaité
qu'on n'était pas très exemplaire
là-dessus plusieurs deuils dans ma
famille dont le dernier qui était la
norme au talent de mon père et qui m'a
fait faire à ce moment là le choix de
délaisser une carrière et de privilégier
le sens et donc j'ai décidé de reprendre
le chemin de cette prise de conscience
une ici en 99 et de mettre mes pas dans
cette trajectoire de sens et d'essayer
de faire comme à vie soit vraiment
cohérente avec avec une valeur et donc
pendant quelques temps j'ai pu voilà
construire faire
certain nombre de choses qui allaient
dans ce sens là continuer rédiger des
livres comment s'est engagé dans
différentes actions
et puis peut-être que j'étais à nouveau
partie dans un certain endormissement
tout cas il semble que je n'ai pas vu
assez les les éléments de les signes de
la vie comme tout à l'heure la flamme du
briquet et la vie m'a à nouveau rattrapé
et des changements que j'avais mise en
place elle m'a apporté quelques
turbulences pour monsieur qu à nouveau
et me ramener dans le droit chemin et
donc je me suis rendu compte que dans
tous les cas de figure les signes
étaient présents mais peut-être que je
savais pas suffisamment les lire et donc
un jour j'ai compris et j'ai compris
grâce à une un texte que j'ai rencontré
un texte de chambre de foucauld que je
vais vous lire et qui me le texte donc
pour charles de foucauld qui était
croyant s'adresser à dieu j'ai vu
l'énergie donc je m'adresse au tout aux
vivants à l'esprit et voilà ce que je me
suis amusé à déclarer avec d'autres amis
je me remets entre vos mains
donc entre les mains du tout je me
convient vous je m'abandonne avoue fait
de moi ce qu'il vous plaira quoi que
vous fassiez de moi je l'accepterais je
vous remercie
merci de tout je suis partout j'accepte
tout je vous remercie de tout haut
là je me suis dit le programme des
festivités
eh ben c'est quand même un petit peu
élevé donc j'ai fait mes amis j'ai dit
ok j'y vais je veux
j'y vais à fond mais simplement je pense
que je vais être traversés 2,3
turbulences quand même et la vie va
écouter
elle m'a dit ah oui tu t'abandonnes tu
dis oui tu oses tu y vas fond d'accord
puisque tu es prête à enlever et donc ça
a commencé par le toutes les choses que
je n'avais pas encore au thé dans ma vie
et qui m'a empêché d'être vraiment dans
cette radicalité de cet appel de 1999 je
pense et le reste va pouvoir essayer de
contribuer au niveau de conscience jean
fallait que je commence par lui et donc
voilà plein de choses m'ont été enlevée
notamment au niveau de on est tous
touchés là où ça fait pincer dans c'est
pas rigolo et donc je voulais plus
travailler avec certaines sociétés
partenaires qui ne marchaient pas leurs
paroles c'est à dire qu'ils qui
dispensait des conseils aux entreprises
sur s'est appliquée à elle même si je
veux plus travailler avec ça la vie
vraie super bien entendu cinq sur cinq
ça s'est arrêté d'un coup avec tous les
oeufs rose entier ok je vais les
consciences genre et tout ce qui va pas
mais j'avais aussi formuler ce voeu
schlotter et je voudrais bien travailler
de telle et telle manière avec tel ou
tel type de personne et là problème de
connexion avec chez valoir j'ai pas été
entendu du tout dans un premier temps
donc la rencontre a lutté avec le vide
on enlève ce qui n'est plus juste tu
veux changer le pack soucis qu'on enlève
tout savoir ce qu'il rate est donc là ça
a été la rencontre avec le vide ça a été
la rencontre avec ce qu'on appelle la
traversée du désert la nuit mystique
pour ceux qui connaissent ce registre là
qu enfin en rien est néanmoins
ça va pas le faire moi j'y crois c'est à
dire que ça n'a pas ébranlé ma foi j'ai
dit mais j'irai jusqu'au bout et je
continuerai à m'engager pour le bien
commun et je continue à mettre au
service a suffi les épreuves que je
continue ma voix ça a duré un certain
monde moi ça m'a mise à genoux au bord
du gouffre au board parfois peut-être
les questions deviennent alors pourquoi
celle à quoi je sers jeudi je
continuerai je ne changerai pas mon
trajet il a bien été bien au bout du
chemin
mais dans l'intervalle y avait un tout
petit peu de ténèbres encore et donc à
quoi ça sert tout ça est bien de pouvoir
se dire que on a confiance en lui en le
vivant il est là et si on a ce désir
dames cette envie d'écouter ce qu'il ya
au plus profond de cette espèce d'élixir
de vie ce concentré de qui nous sommes
pourquoi chacun de nous sur terre qu'est
ce qu'on est venu faire qu'est ce qu'on
est venu délivrer si on écoute ça et
qu'on le mur en face en vis à vis à
l'école du vivant mais ça marche
évidemment ça coupe tout ce qui entre
dans tous les les masses que les trucs
superflu tout est parti et c'était
formidable deuxième engagé confiance j'y
vais car depuis les cadeaux les
coopérations les aides les soutiens
générosité c'était juste extraordinaire
j'avais beaucoup donné avant les simples
s'attendent de retour sur investissement
mais alors c'était super chouette un
bonheur intérieur
et donc j'en suis maintenant va vouloir
partager les leçons à vouloir simplement
les transmettre chacun aura bien ce
qu'il veut j'ai fait ma cueillette et je
vais vous la remet donc les messages
c'est que tout est là
c'est à dire que si on éclaire avec qui
on veut être avec qui ont mené avec son
design tout est là les signes sont là
comme tout à l'heure le briquet en
premier responsable le voir donc et si
l'essentiel c'est dans les détails
ça va donner la vie vous ferais bien ce
que vous voulez mais ça comme
extraordinaire beaucoup peut-être par
muse s'engager avec l'autre personne
avant une femme c'est une énorme c'est
encore plus grande
j'y vais à fond et j'y crois et tout est
parfait ça c'est très difficile à
entendre quand on est dans un moment de
souffrance et de demander licka et
douloureux néanmoins c'est vraiment
extraordinaire deuxième combat oui
évidemment tout ça je n'en voulais pas
je n'en voulait plus la ville m'a écouté
l enlever est ce que je souhaitais pour
être sûr j'étais au niveau de ce que je
m'étais donné comme objectif elle a
attendu des prouver ma foi une fois
qu'elle a vu que c'était pour de vrai
alors il ya de médicaments voilà et le
dernier point est bien c'est de poser
c'est pas dans les traces du vivant
voilà c'est ce que je nous souhaite et
je vous remercie